escribe un polinomio que exprese el
valor total de p billetes de 20 pesos
como monedas de 10 pesos y r monedas de
5 pesos ok entonces tenemos de billetes
de 20 pesos y cuántos pesos valen esos
pe billetes de 20 pesos pues como
tenemos pe billetes vamos a poner por
aquí una p y cada uno de esos billetes
vale 20 pesos aunque entonces en total
todos esos billetes juntos valen 20 por
p pesos ahora pasemos a las comuneras de
10 pesos y es exactamente lo mismo
tenemos por aquí q monedas y cada una de
esas monedas vale 10 pesos entonces para
encontrar el valor total de esas monedas
lo que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar
por 10
porque tenemos q monedas que valen 10 y
lo mismo pasa con las ere monedas de 5
pesos cada moneda vale 5 pesos y tenemos
ere de ellas entonces en total todas
estas juntas valen 5 por ere y pues nos
piden el valor total así es que si
tenemos 20 por pesos en billetes de 20
pesos y 10 por q pesos en monedas de 10
pesos entonces en total tenemos 20 por
pesos más 10 por q pesos ok pero también
tenemos de monedas de 5 pesos así es que
también tenemos que sumarlas y pues eso
es todo este es tal cual el polinomio
que nos pidieron polinomio lo único que
significa es que son varios términos
aunque hay de hecho podríamos decir que
este es un trinomio porque tiene tres
términos pero bueno esto expresa el
valor total de nuestros billetes y
monedas